we are back with battlefield's broken
busted absurd and just straight up op
weapons of
all time what's up all i'm david and in
our last video
a bunch of you hopped into the comments
and dropped some great weapons that
weren't shown in part one
now we love making these videos and if
you enjoy watching them
drop us a like if you're new to the
channel as well then welcome
subscribe so you'll be up to date on all
things battlefield and be sure to hit
that bell button
let's dive in overwhelmingly requested
in the comments of our last video the
m26 dart isn't
actually its own weapon but is a
specific shotgun attachment
so it's two parts the underbarrel
shotgun itself
known as the m26 mass and the type of
rounds used which are dart rounds
the m26 dart wasn't just overpowered it
was straight
up broken battlefield 3 players quickly
noticed a glitch where each individual
dart pellet took on the damage of the
gun that it was attached to
now the glitch worked for things like
buckshot ammo as well according to
forums and guides online
however the dart rounds had far greater
range
similar to the type of killstreaks
players could go on with the infamous
usas12 shotgun
the m26 dart caused enemy players to
want to rip their hair out in
frustration
just pure absolute nonsense of a weapon
[Applause]
battlefield 1's gameplay had trench
warfare at its heart
and few weapons clear trenches out like
the model 10a
this shotgun shined above its brethren
such as the m97 and the 12g
and was extremely popular now when i say
extremely popular
i don't just mean an influx of players
began using it thanks to content
creators pointing out the 10a
statistical advantage
over comparable shotguns no i mean just
look at the data of shotgun usage in
battlefield 1
and you'll see a gob stopping 60 plus
percent of shotgun users
use the 10a that is
absolutely hilarious if you die from a
shotgun
there was a strong chance it was to the
10a and man does this thing do work
it is a monstrous cleanup type gun that
finishes kills at range
it can even be effective at mid-range
sometimes but obviously it shines the
brightest and close quarter encounters
now there are some inconsistencies with
the gun despite its popularity
folks online have complained that this
seems to be a gun where
other people who use it win but when i
use it i lose
still its damage is undeniable destroy
your enemies with one shot at close
range in the gut
the arm the leg wherever take your pick
[Music]
the m2 the m2 carl gustav
recoilless anti-tank rifle is in a
slightly different position than the
rest of the entries on this list and
that it is utilized situationally
with the intention of disabling vehicles
obviously
the m2 is a powerful addition to the
engineer's arsenal and although the
purpose of the weapon
is to operate as an anti-tank and
anti-air weapon at times players used
the m2 as an
anti-infantry weapon much to the ire of
other players
by design the m2 had huge areas of
impact
but contrary to other big anti-vehicle
weapons like an rpg
the m2 had less total damage but a lot
of splash damage
this meant that it might take a couple
direct hits to disable the tank
but you could wipe out infantry just by
shooting in the general vicinity
the main gripe that the online community
had with the m2
was that it just didn't quite fit the
goal of playing the engineer class
because being forgiving enough to let
the engineer moonlight as an assault
class
using their arsenal as an anti-infantry
kit just gave the engineers a larger
advantage over selecting other classes
which isn't fair and the extremely
forgiving splash damage led to a lot
of frustration this gun might feel like
it's not
quite as overpowered or blatantly broken
but no one can deny that it is extremely
above
average at its worst and infuriating to
go up against at its best
one of the most common guns in the game
for the assault class and extremely
popular
the aek 971 sports several advantages
for starters the majority of its stats
are all above average
allowing the weapon to be reliable in
all close encounter engagements
as well as some fights at medium range
for more skilled players that can handle
its recoil
the gun has a very high rate of fire and
feels good to use at
900 rpm making it the second fastest
rifle in the game
a lot of posts online are of the opinion
that the gun is very low skill to
utilize
since so many of its stats are forgiving
which to them
means that the weapon must be a crutch
whether or not this is true
is hard for me to say personally because
there is a consistent trend
where if more players are using a weapon
and shifting the meta
then the assumption becomes that all the
low-skilled players must be using the
weapon as well
which isn't necessarily true however it
is hard to deny the weapons popularity
and advantages granting the aek 971
a spot on this list alright
once again the smg's show their faces on
this list for being overpowered
this time with yet another battlefield 1
weapon the smg-0818
it's perks incredible magazine size and
fast time to kill
the only close quarter counter possible
is a model 10a hunter or another
comparable shotgun
now the smg-0818 does qualify as a
contender for the question of
is it truly broken or is it simply
annoying and a popular weapon of choice
for newbies
the sentiment online is that the
smg-0818 is the ultimate weapon of
choice for
bad players and is a low-skilled ceiling
weapon
new players can just spray and pray
letting the gun do all the heavy lifting
as a dlc weapon it takes a minute to
unlock
but it's not particularly difficult
meaning that the weapon was quickly in
the hands of hordes of players
wreaking havoc across the battlefield
battlefield hardline the underrated dark
horse of the franchise
the forgotten middle child although
battlefield veterans might overlook
hardline at times
one thing that absolutely refused to be
forgotten was the k10
smg similar to the nambu type 2a that
appeared in battlefield v
and made our part 1 list of most broken
weapons the k10 smg introduced
a lot of familiar traits specifically
one of the highest firing rates in the
franchise
with an rpm of 1200 that's not to say
the k10 didn't have any drawbacks
there is a significant damage drop off
to anything beyond 30 meters
but if you were in that sweet spot
between 10 to 30 meters
there was a high chance you were about
to become godlike the small magazine of
the k10 meant constantly reloading
however not only was the reload fast
enough to make this drawback minor
but the time to kill was so strong you
could wipe out multiple enemies before
the magazine had emptied
the nambu type 2a was certified busted
in the later game
in battlefield v but the k10 did it all
first
now here's a bonus one that will make
anyone grown in despair if you played
battlefield 4.
it's not a weapon but a utility the suav
aircraft was a super small moving drone
that could cause road kills meaning one
hit ko utility by simply flying
close enough to opponents which means
we're all just living
in one big meme simulation absolutely
hilarious if you were using it
absolutely painful to watch if you had
any self-respect or empathy
and nothing short of infuriating if you
died to it
so many of you gave me great weapons to
hunt down online and read up on how
broken they were pre-patched throughout
battlefield's history so a big
thank you personally out of all of them
i found the suav to be
genuinely appalling but from a pure
weapons point of view
i think the m26 dart took the crown
because it was
literally busted like you had to
activate an actual glitch
now i've always thought that dice
sandboxes were pretty balanced once the
patches and fixes came in
but i want to know what you guys think
so let me know if there's any guns that
i missed
and if there's enough you can count on
seeing me return with a part three
thanks for watching
you